at this time police on the scene of
another murder after a rash of violence
here over the weekend thank you for
joining us at six i'm brian loftis and
i'm christian casarez police just
wrapped up a briefing on the latest one
officers are on the scene of the latest
deadly shooting near
lake mead and hollywood 8 news now
madison kimbrough was at the press
conference police
just held madison
yeah we're currently here on menden lane
right at the northeast part of the
valley
you can take a look behind me as you can
see metro is still on scene has been on
scene for hours now
and what we have been told by officials
is that one man
is dead after being shot this happened
around 2 40 today
that man died on scene as of now we
don't have a description of the man we
don't know his age but we do know
this is the fourth homicide metro has
dealt with this past weekend alone
they say this area that you're looking
at right now of the neighborhood will be
blocked off
for several hours again they have been
here for a couple hours now and again
officials are saying that this area will
be blocked off
probably for the next two or three hours
reporting live madison kimbrough 8 news
now